I know you're a huge reader but from a a
lifelong learning perspective constantly
trying to add to your toolkit so that
you're you know a better leader a better
CEO are there recommendations that you
have for the audience about those kinds
of things that you do to keep yourself
mentally sharp well I read a lot less
these days than I used to when I was a
kid I was read all the time I mean
mostly subscribe to Scientific computer
articles the The Daily News I find to be
a lot of noise
um and just very negative seem to be
trying to answer the question what is
the worst thing that happened on Earth
today something job will happen every
single day and also something great
happens but I don't answer that question
and I find Twitter enlightening at times
you know learn learn about there and
talking to smart people all the time is
very helpful because that can be a
distillation of of interesting things
that are going on I try to ask people
like for the car like what are we doing
wrong and like what can we make better
like how do we do less wrong hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because as a young entrepreneur I
struggle to keep my business going when
I had no friends I had no mentors I had
no role models and the thing that saved
me was learning from the success stories
of famous entrepreneurs and in their
stories I got motivation and I also got
strategies for what I could do to grow
my business and not stay stuck and I
still need their stories for motivation
today so today let's learn the habits of
highly successful people enjoy
habit number two is manage your time
better with Jeff Bezos there are a lot
of things that are a waste of time you
know when you think about your life I
think I I often tell people
um that I work with if you can get
because people people have very high
standards for how they want their work
life to be and uh and I said look if you
can get your work life to be where you
enjoy half of it
that is a home that is amazing because
very few people ever achieve that
because the truth is everything comes
with overhead that's reality everything
comes with pieces that you don't like
you could be a Supreme Court Justice and
there's still going to be pieces of your
job you don't like you can be a
university professor and still going to
be you have to go to committee meetings
and you have to do you know their every
job comes with pieces you don't like and
we need to say that's just how that's
part of it uh and and and not resent
those pieces or try not to but also try
to minimize them I tell senior
executives
you should have the least stress you
know there's this weird I think false uh
idea that CEOs I'm a CEO there's this
false idea that CEOs are under the most
stress
well I look at that I'm like why you're
in charge
why don't you delegate the stress it's
your choice and uh so it's you have to
figure out how to set up your life in
such a way that you can minimize the
things and I find people don't dislike
hard work what people dislike and is
being out of control
like they can't control their life they
can't control their environment this
happens to me when I get over scheduled
I hate being over scheduled I want some
time to be able to think and free myself
we all have the same amount of time in
the world nobody has more time than
anybody else and when you become a very
successful person one of the things you
start to get over scheduled you have
this event you had to agree to do this
and maybe last night you're like why did
I agree to do this I have to go on stage
tomorrow I wish I would really with my
family and you know or I hope maybe not
this case let's say that you'd like this
one but in general that kind of thing
happens and so you have to guard your
time and and try to save a little bit
flexible so that's for me it's not a
waste of time but I like to have some
freedom of movement
rather than having every minute of every
day scheduled also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
work sheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
habit number three is Think Like an
investor with Warren Buffett I'm a
bright guy who's terribly interested in
what he does so I've spent a lifetime
doing it I've surrounded my myself with
people that bring out the best in me and
you don't need to be a genius in what I
do that's the good thing about it if I
went in the physics or so I just a whole
lot of other subjects I've been also rap
but I am in a game
that you don't need you probably need
120 points of IQ you know but you but
170 doesn't do any better than 120 it
may do worse probably do worse but but
uh
you don't really need
brains what do you need you need the
right orientation you know ninety
percent of the people I'm putting a
figure out the air but ninety percent of
the people that buy stocks don't think
of them the right way
they think about something they hope
goes up next week and they think about
the market is something they help goes
up and if it's down they feel worse I
feel better and you think about
10 or 20 years from now
and I hope it goes down when I buy it
because I'll buy more habit number four
is maximize your productivity with Sam
Altman focusing more specifically on
productivity like what are some life
hacks that maybe you apply to make your
everyday more productive I mean I think
there's like a lot of crap written about
productivity secrets on the internet and
people sort of like get into this
thing where they spend more time like
trying to be productive about their
productivity system and actually getting
things done
um
I I will say I think that
well I'll say two I think pieces of
advice that aren't obvious
um one is I think far more important
than any particular system is just
figuring out the right things to work on
and so all of the time that people spend
with like this new productivity app or
that or whatever would be better spent
like really trying to think diligently
about
I have the same number of hours as
anybody else what am I going to spend
them on and getting that right is more
important than exactly like being
perfectly productive with those hours
um
a big part of that is not doing things
that waste time I think if you can just
like focus on the things that are
important and not do the things that
waste time you can be fairly sloppy with
productivity otherwise and you'll still
get far more done than most people
um
it's it's really hard to do that the
other thing that I think people don't
think about enough is figuring out your
own personal like rhythms of
productivity
and there's huge variants I've noticed
between people that figure this out and
don't so like for me personally it turns
out that I am most productive if I go to
sleep late wake up late and then keep
the first like three or four hours of
the day and don't schedule any meetings
like work from home like get through my
list of stuff then and then like pack
all my meetings when I'm kind of less
productive it's just grinding stuff out
or thinking creatively in the afternoon
um and like it took me some number of
years to figure it out because it didn't
like fit well with the work schedule I
was naturally in but then I was like all
right if this is like the thing to that
makes me most productive
then I'm gonna like make my whole
schedule work to support that and that
was like a really important change for
me so I think figuring out your own
personal like Optimal times to work on
what kind of different things uh people
don't really talk about that much and at
least for me it had a huge impact and
habit number five the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is
practice meditation with Ray dalio
whatever success I've had has come more
from meditation than any other
thing any other influence and you and I
um no because you you're you're a
meditator your wife's a meditator we
meditated in your
um room your meditation room
um we know what it is and I'll explain
what it is
um
um it it I'll first explain what it
gives you and then I'll explain how it
gives you it gives it to you
um it gives you an Equanimity a ability
to almost rise above yourself and to see
things in this
um thoughtful way almost like uh a ninja
in a uh Ninja movie as things are coming
at them everything's sooner seems slower
and you approach it and you can deal
with it in that way and it gives you
um a greater level of creativity and it
does that by uh connecting your
subconscious to your conscious it
achieves that by repeating a mantra so
here's how it works there's a sound that
doesn't have a meaning it's a sound we
could for example it could be something
like oh and mentally you repeat that
over and over again you close your eyes
you get uncomfortable position and you
repeat that and you'll find that your
mind will go to that but then it'll go
to thoughts and you just say oh it's in
thoughts and go back to home and you get
to practice it and what after a while
you'll stay in that meditation that
Mantra and then when you're in that
Mantra
um it will then disappear and then you
go into a Transcendent state in other
words you transcend and you're going
basically into your subconscious and
you're in your subconscious and your
subconscious is really what controls you
more than your conscious you know it's
just you're just not conscious of it
because when you're conscious you know
you think oh well what do I want to do
and so on but your subconscious has such
an influence of the things you've
learned in your earlier years or your
genetics or something and they're not
aware from you and when you go down into
that
um you get relief but you also
um help to make the connection between
your subconscious and your conscious and
so when they're aligned you're aligning
your emotional decisions with your
intellectual decisions so I find uh it's
an instinctual thing for me to do what
do I feel emotionally what do I feel
what do I do think about that
intellectually and then how do I
approach that in that calm way it
doesn't diminish your emotions
um uh it just is you feel them
differently and my my love is as much as
it has ever been my um or more maybe
because I feel it differently so I just
want to emphasize it doesn't take away
your emotions or anything it just puts
them in the perspective as though and
you look above yourself and you see
yourself within the life's Arc you see
the strengths and the weaknesses and how
to deal with them and you navigate
better
you have a single most important core
value and when you figure it out your
entire life changes if you feel like
you're being pulled in a million
different directions
you're walking on quicksand everybody
wants something from you you're hot and
cold you want to do something one day
and you don't the other day you have a
hard time saying no to people and to
Opportunities and you're just being
pulled in a thousand directions does
that sound familiar does it sound like
you
if that's you
you don't know what you stand for
because when you know what you stand for
all decisions become easier
I wrote two books on this you're one
word and then built the serve and at the
core both of them is figuring out what
what do you stand for what is your
single most important core value and
when you can name it when you can label
it when you can get to the root of it
what it does is give you Clarity for the
rest of your life
minus belief my one word is belief
I want to believe in myself more and I
want to spread belief to the world to
the people around me it's why I make all
these videos
I make them for myself because I need to
learn and I want to be around the best I
want to be around people who inspire me
to believe more in myself and I try to
spread that to the world
it becomes a filter through which I see
the world it becomes the filter through
which my best self operates
whenever I don't know what to do
whenever I'm given an opportunity
whenever I might be pulled in a thousand
different directions
what do I run that through as well
believe
what would the believe version of Evan
do what would he do
and then that just makes it easier
boom decision made
easier
if you look at my YouTube Channel people
say well you do all these top 10 rules
and you do all these inspiring videos
it's great why not do top 10 of the
stupidest things this person said
or top 10 reasons why not to follow this
person
if I did that if I if I went negative on
Kanye West or Donald Trump or whoever
those videos would actually do better
you know this is where it gets really
tough this is where it really comes down
to what you stand for and how much do
you stand for because when you can get
to the core of who you are that becomes
a lot easier because
making those videos if I was to slam
people
would do better people would much rather
watch negative videos than positive
people would much rather laugh at
somebody else than educate themselves
it's just just how we are we'd rather
watch
big brother and watch reality TV shows
and people tearing each other apart you
can't look away from a car accident or
fight on the street we have this thing
inside us where we like seeing other
people
not doing well because that's how we
feel better about ourselves when you see
somebody else struggling to see someone
else's terrible life on TV you feel
better about yourself so we have this we
have this insecurity inside all of us
and so those videos would do better or
top 10 stupidest things Kanye West has
said would would get more views would
make me more money would lead to more
subscribers would lead to all the
metrics that
that you would probably look at right
you know if I look at what are my goals
do I want more subscribers more views
more comments more Revenue it would help
all of that
but it's anti-belief
I don't wanna I feel gross I don't want
to put that content out I don't want to
put up content slamming people it's not
who I am it's not what makes me come
alive
and this is where you could do it for a
short amount of time and you're going to
start to burn out because you start to
hate your life because you're doing work
that is just against who you want to be
you look at Dave Hollis he's got his one
word of Captain great so what does a
captain do
Captain goes through choppy Waters
Captain is built for the rough Seas
so if he's ever stuck thinking about
should I do this or not well what would
a captain do
and then boom answer
so figuring out your one word figuring
out that most important core value what
it does is give you a road map
for the rest of your life and it it
never gets old I will never stop
believing
in myself and others and wanting to
continue to inspire Dave Hollis will
never stop wanting to be the captain
and you need to figure out what yours is
because that gives you direction again
for the rest of your life
so how do we do it how do what are some
of the tactics what are some of the
tricks that you can use because I think
this is one of the most important
exercises you can ever do in your life
understanding what you stand for as a
human
it's not it's not taught you know in
schools it's not taught in textbooks
most of the people who've taught you in
schools they're not happy with the
direction of their life either right
like as you start to get older when
you're when you're a kid and you look at
your parents and adults you feel like
they got it all figured out they have
the answers and then you realize they
have no idea what they're doing like
they're barely hanging on themselves
the teachers have taught you about you
know life and in school they're not
happy with their own life
they haven't figured this out either
but I think it's one of the most
important things that we can learn so
again I have two books on it you're one
word built to serve you want to go
deeper those are great resources but you
start with what are some of the things
that make you come alive
who was your favorite teacher growing up
what movies did you love growing up what
did you love about how your parents
raised you even if you hate your parents
was there anything that you can pull out
that you loved
and what you're doing is looking at what
are some of the things that tie these
things together
so if you had the right this is the
exercise I did with people
okay tell me your favorite movie and
three words to describe it
tell me who your favorite teacher was
and three words to describe them think
about your favorite teacher growing up
favorite coach your favorite mentor
bought you grade 8 science
right it wasn't that material they
taught you they made you feel better as
a human they taught you how to be a
better person why what did they do
I was talking to a woman yesterday
coaching her through this process we did
an Instagram live together she's part of
my movement makers program and just past
a year being in the program so we did a
live together and she wanted to go
through this exercise how do I find my
one word
and her favorite teacher growing up
wasn't a teacher but was her coach she
was a track coach and one of the things
that she loved about the track coach was
he would get in and do it with her
so whenever she was tired whenever she
wanted to quit whenever she didn't feel
good enough he wouldn't just give her
words but he would do it with her he'd
say okay
I'll do the last one with you race me
he would run alongside her
so as you think about it what what was
your favorite teacher growing up who was
it and and why write down
some descriptive keywords and what
you'll find is if you do that with who
your favorite mentors are who your
favorite teachers are what your favorite
books or videos are look at my Channel
all the people we profiled and who were
the people that you resonate with the
most if you love me what are three words
of whatever Carmichael that you love you
love Dave Hollis what are three words
that describe Dave Hollis you know all
the good things that that you love that
make you feel alive and bold and
confident and serving and wanting to
help all those things are connected
but they don't feel connected this is
the problem this is the the connective
tissue work that you have to do this is
where
we never learn these things the things
that you love are not just random
occurrences they're connected
[Music]
when you write them down the descriptive
keywords you'll see a trend that happens
between them
so for me it's belief my favorite movie
is Seabiscuit it's about a horse that's
too small and a jockey that's too big
and a team owner that's going bankrupt
and somehow they come together find each
other and win all of these races and
it's based off a true story and they go
and beat the the well-funded you know
the team that has the perfect jockey and
the giant horse and the tons of money
and they go and they beat those guys
right so if I were to write down you
know the three words believe is on there
I might say Underdog I might say
inspiring I might say believe I would
say believe you know and then if I think
about my favorite teacher growing up
Madame Farr taught me French but I don't
even use my French like French isn't
even that valuable for the work that I
do why do I love Madame far well because
she believed in me because she would
meet with me once a week when I was in
my
graduating year
and she just asked me about my life how
I was doing in school I was introverted
I was shy
you know it was harder for me to make
friends and feel like I fit in and
belonged and so for her I might put
belong I would definitely put the leave
and I might put something else maybe
care or compassion
in those meetings with her once a week
turned me from a b c student into a
straight A student when I didn't think
that that was possible for for me to do
it because I never really gotten A's my
entire School career so
we started to look at the similarities
right that I'm far
believe you know compassion Etc
Seabiscuit Underdog believe right
there's different keywords that will
show up but what's a consistent one
believe
that's interesting
it's interesting this keeps coming up
what would happen if I built my whole
life throughout belief
what would happen if I built my business
around belief what would happen if I
created a schedule
and a calendar and habits and routines
that made me feel more belief what would
happen if I could spread that belief to
others what would happen if I brought on
team members who love believe and helped
spread believe with their skills and
talents what would happen if I had my
significant other
believe in me right what would happen
What would how much has life changed
everything
because now I'm designing a life
with intent
and purpose
and with design
as opposed to randomly having things
experienced
for me to me because everybody's got an
agenda for your time everybody wants you
to do certain things
and that's when you feel lost and being
pulled in a million different directions
you have to figure out what you stand
for I think it's the most important
thing you can do as a human what do you
stand for what's your single most
important core value
some people get it right away from the
exercises some people take some time and
you you sit on it and it becomes more
and more right or more and more wrong
but when you find it
and you get that Compass you get that
road map it's with you for the rest of
your life it makes every decision easier
it makes you live a lot more in
alignment and makes you feel like what
you're doing is important that it
matters it gives you the confidence and
the Courage the thing that you're afraid
to do to step outside your comfort zone
to build the business in the life that
you want
and ultimately to make you happy
to make you happy
and then you can spread that happiness
to others will help them believe in
themselves too when you think about
education and self-education what do you
recommend I'd encourage people to read a
lot of books just read like basically
try to ingest as much information as you
can
uh and try to also just develop a good
general knowledge
um
so so you at least have like
a roughly of the land of the knowledge
landscape
like try to learn a little about about a
lot of things
because you might not know what you're
really interested how would you know
what you're really interested in if you
at least aren't like doing it peripheral
exploration and broadly of
of
the knowledge landscape
um
and you talk to people from different
walks of life and different uh
Industries and professions and skills
and occupations like just try you know
learn as much as possible I would
encourage people to read broadly in many
different subject areas
um
and and and then try to find something
where there's an overlap of your talents
and and what you're interested in so
people may be good at something but
although they may have skill at a
particular thing but they don't like
doing it
um so you want to try to find a thing
where you have your that's a good a good
uh combination of of yours of the things
that you're inherently good at but you
also like doing you have a competitive
Spirit clearly yeah
clearly well but you gotta you gotta be
careful about what you competed you know
it's a good thing I don't have a
competitive Spirit In chess or you know
you know or football or anything like
that well I just I've I've been an
observer there I I enjoy watching things
like that
but I I try to keep my competitive
experience in a game where I can win do
you have a killer instinct
nah not exactly I've got I wouldn't call
it a Killer Instinct but I do I do know
this well I want to do something I
always want to do it big
I put my whole net worth in City service
preferred you know 120 dollars
114.75
I put my whole net worth and and I've
never
since I was
well since that day and you know March
11 1942 I have never had less than 80
percent of my money in American business
you can call them stocks or equities but
I see them as American Business I I've
owned a piece of American Business
for
eight at least eighty percent
at all times in you know I've just I
don't want to own anything else I went
on a home and you know things my family
wants and all that but owning five homes
doesn't mean anything to me because I'm
going to be happy in one home and
there's a certain amount of things that
go wrong with everything and if I got
two homes I know I've got more problems
and I don't have more happiness what
brings you the happiness oh that
I would have to be honestly say that
that what makes me happiest is what I'm
doing what I'm doing you know I I
allocating I enjoy two things about it
one
I know I'll win over time that I mean
I'll beat everybody else or anything
like that but I'll I I mean the game is
very very very easy if you have the
right
lessons in your mind about what you're
buying I'm not buying stocks I'm buying
pieces of overwhelmingly American
Business uh and I'm happy
when that's happy when that's uh when
I'm doing it I'm happy when stocks are
going down I'm happier when stocks are
going down because I I can buy more of
them with the same amount of money I'd
be happy if I was a farmer I'd want
Farmland to go down so I could buy more
acreage you know if I was I mean it just
makes sense you got to sell yeah because
the in my experiences the the CEOs the
owners the founders that didn't sell
they all failed yeah with no exceptions
a hundred percent of them failed and you
know when you're just starting and it's
just you who else is going to sell
nobody
and that's the other you know and that
leads to another mistake entrepreneurs
make they they try to hit hiring home
runs right so when the minute they hit a
roadblock I'll just hire a you know I'll
hire a new marketing person right or
I'll hire a new head of sales
um I hope thinking that oh this person's
amazing no one's ever hired somebody and
said they suck really bad of course
right oh I found the most amazing person
why did they leave the last five jobs oh
they were amazing but right
um that's such a good point see that's
what I love how your brain works it's
like exactly it's so true it's so
practical and common sense it's
pragmatic yeah right common sense but
Common Sense isn't so common no I know
you know you just ask why why'd they
leave you know but but entrepreneurs
tend to think okay I'm hiring this
amazing marketing person and he or she
is is going to know what to do yeah and
then they tell that to their investors
because that's typically why they're
hiring a marketing person and they say
oh this person's amazing you know our
next quarter is going to be great then
it's not then they go to the next
marketing person you know then they're
in this hamster wheel again and they're
screwed and so we're relying on other
people well yes and that's the whole
thing right you you've got to be able to
solve the problems yourself self-reliant
now you know at some point your business
gets bigger and you have to learn how to
do a lot of other things you know when
you go to five people it's one thing you
go to 10 or 15 it's another challenge
you know as you learn how to manage and
deal with people but at the same time if
you're not great at your core competency
how are you going to train those people
right how are you going to know what the
the goals are for the organization how
to communicate to them how to do what
you need them to do the biggest impact a
company can have is staying within its
area of expertise so
you know to make sure that the education
systems around the world that they get
good software and we have a donation
program where we've done called called
Partners in learning we have deals with
132 countries how we grant them software
and fun teacher training in each of
those countries so Microsoft's main
thing will be about that Library access
that school access the free software the
training you know the job skills and the
partners that are in that country uh not
not so much health care and whereas the
big drug companies we need to get them
into the health care issues and the
banks we need to get into microfinance
and the food companies we need to get
into micronutrients and buying the
output of the farmers in these poor
countries so that the their economies
get going so I think everybody's got a
big role to play but it's it's going to
be fairly centered on the thing that
that the employees know and uh drives
their their specific contribution Jeff
built one of the greatest technology
companies in the world in just 20 some
years you've taken a company from
nothing to Amazon which everybody in the
world now knows and and most people in
the world seem to use was that harder to
do than trying to get a space company
off the ground which is more of a
challenge to you
totally different challenges so one of
the things that I find if I think back
on the last 20 years you have to
remember 20 years ago I was driving the
packages to the post office myself in my
1987 Chevy Blazer dreaming that one day
I might be able to afford a forklift and
the internet that's 1995 and you know 21
years later the internet is this
gigantic thing and there are many many
successful companies and
the entrepreneurial dynamism
that you see on the internet is
incredible and really with blue origin
you know that this new challenge that
I'm taking on with blue origin what I
want to do is put the heavy lifting
infrastructure in place so that the Next
Generation can have a dynamic
entrepreneurial explosion of ideas and
inventions in space just like we've had
with the internet and the reason you
can't do that today is because there's
just too much heavy lifting involved
literally you know getting to space is
so expensive and so hard when we started
Amazon I didn't have to build a
logistics infrastructure system to
deliver Parcels there was something
already UPS already existed in the U.S
Postal Service already existed I didn't
need to build a remote payment system
there are already credit cards and
similarly you know there were computers
around and you know that didn't have to
get all those things would have been
tens of billions or hundreds of billions
of dollars of infrastructure the long
distance phone network became the
backbone of the internet but it already
existed and so you could have this
Dynamic entrepreneurial explosion
because all the heavy capex
infrastructure was in place for space
it's not like that the price of
admission is so high so that's the big
difference and what I'm super excited
about is lowering that cost I want to
dramatically lower that cost so that 20
years from now a new generation of
people with startup money real real
entrepreneurs small entrepreneurs can do
amazing things in space think how cool
that would be I've always
had the philosophy that's you know screw
it just do it is a lot more fun than
than not scary
and and sometimes it's got me into a lot
of trouble and sometimes more often than
not it's been it's been fantastic and
um so you know I suppose one of my
greatest fear in life is saying no to
something and then regretting it so
um so I have said yes a lot and
and in the case of um you know the
learning Adventures
um yeah the helicoster's my life but it
it helped put virgin on the map on a
global basis and
um and you know help help get the brand
established and
um and it was actually great fun when it
when it was going well and it was
actually terrifying when it wasn't it
was the first um time that uh well five
people had actually tried to cross the
Atlantic five people that died so it was
it was the um it was the an attempt to
try to do it differently than the others
had done it and that was to fly in the
jet stream at 35 000 feet where you've
got very strong winds uh to be above the
bad weather
um and um uh and you know we were the
first and then and then foolishly we
decided to do the Pacific
um and a lot a lot of exciting things
went wrong on the way but
um we missed Los Angeles I think by two
and a half thousand miles which is what
we were aiming for and it the Arctic but
um but they were they were great
adventures the greatest problem of
mankind I believe wow that's a big
statement the greatest problem of
mankind
and it is an exceptional problem at this
moment in time
is people having opinions that they're
stuck on
that
um they won't you know like I have to
have my opinion and that's right and so
on because it prevents them
from
um resolving it from moving forward to
finding the best answer from
compromising and or doing you know so
like everybody's arguing over everything
and and they and you know they're it's
almost like they're killing each other
and and we're in a society
um you know I have another principle
which is when the causes that you're
behind are more important to you and
others than the system the system is in
Jeopardy so do you are you just
literally going to go fight so here we
are as we think will we fight or we have
or will we have protocols for having
thoughtful disagreements and getting
past them you guys that are just getting
started you're not going to start right
here
you're going to start down there okay
probably in another city another town I
grew up in Lake Charles Louisiana no
money raised by a single mother I was in
debt at 25 years old the first thing
that I had to do in my life was not
learn a new skill
the first thing I had to do to get my
life moving in the right direction was
self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that I
improved myself and I could start
depending upon me I had to show up every
day with some rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself to do the
right thing every day one of the things
that I started doing was beating the Sun
up every morning
I'm gonna beat that son up every morning
so that I have the discipline and the
control of over my life
so I knew hey before that thing pops I'm
gonna pop I'm gonna get out of bed
depend on myself get up at the same time
every day and for me that time
regardless of where I was was beat that
son up no matter where I am I'm gonna
beat that thing up so it gives me a
sense of control over my own life second
thing I had to start cleaning up my life
and my friends and my environment when I
was younger between 15 and 25 I was
doing crazy stuff in my life
wasting my weekends I had the same
weekends or for the week
I was drinking
fooling around with a bunch of bad
things bad people making poor choices
at 25 years old I cleaned it all up quit
going to those places quit using those
things quit hanging out with people that
did not have ethics and discipline in
their life that weren't committed to the
same things that I was
I wanted to build something in my life I
wanted to become someone and to do that
to become someone in the eyes of the
world the first thing I had to do was
become someone I could depend on so put
some things together three or four
things you can do every day to start the
day
kick start your day get going in your
day to give you a sense of respect for
yourself accomplishment for yourself
look just beating that scent up every
morning gives me the sense of
accomplishment that I did what I said
said I was going to do that I woke up
when I said I would wake up and I
started building respect for myself
start believing in myself so that I can
go out into the world and maybe maybe
maybe today maybe today when I go into
this meeting that I'm dressed for maybe
they'll believe in me as much as I
believe in me and that'll show up in a
contract a deal maybe even some money
beat the Sun up do something you're very
passionate about
and don't try to chase what is kind of
the hot Passion of the day I think we
actually saw this I think you see it all
over the place in many different
contexts but I think we saw it in the
internet World quite a bit where you
know at the sort of peak of the uh sort
of Internet uh you know Mania and say
1999 you found people who were uh you
know very passionate something they kind
of left that job and decided I'm gonna
you know go do something in the internet
because it's you know it was almost like
the you know the 1849 gold rush in a way
I mean you find that people if you go
back and study the history of the 1849
Gold Rush you find that you know at that
time everybody who was in was within the
shouting distance of California was you
know they might have been a doctor but
they quit being a doctor and they
started panning for gold
[Laughter]
and that that almost never works
um and even if it does work uh you know
According to some Metric financial
success or whatever it might be I
suspect it leaves you ultimately
unsatisfied so you really need to
be very clear with yourself and I think
one of the best ways to do that is this
notion of projecting yourself forward to
age 80 looking back on your life and
trying to make sure you've minimized the
number of regrets you have I think you
know you can over worship and
mythologize the idea of working
extremely hard for my particular makeup
I mean it really is true that I didn't
believe in weekends I didn't believe in
vacations I mean you know I knew
everybody's license plate so I could
tell you over the last month when their
car had come and gone from the parking
lot is so I don't recommend it a I don't
think most people would enjoy it uh once
I got into my 30s I could hardly even
imagine how I had done that uh because
by then some natural behavior kicked in
and I loved weekends and uh you know my
girlfriend liked vacations and that
turned out to be kind of a neat thing
now I take lots of vacations my 20 year
old self is so disgusted with my current
uh uh self you know I I was sure I would
never do anything about riding coach you
know now I have a plane so it's it's
very much counter-revelations have taken
place at high speed but yes it is nice
if during those first several years
if you have a team that's chosen to be
pretty maniacal about the company and
how far that goes you should have a
mutual understanding see or not uh one
person expecting one thing another
person expecting another thing
and you'll have individuals who who have
you know health or relatives or things
that are distracted but yes I have a
fairly hardcore View
that there should be a very large uh
sacrifice made during those those early
years how come you haven't bought Amazon
is there still time to buy would you
still buy it oh I I always admired Jeff
I mean I met him 20 years ago or so and
and
I thought it was something special but I
didn't realize you could go from books
to it what's happened there no I I mean
he had a vision and executed in an
incredible way something that it would
not have you know that but there's a lot
of games I miss I would have missed you
know I would have missed Microsoft even
if I got into no bill earlier or
something those just aren't my games I
don't worry about the things that I miss
that are outside my circle of competence
of evaluating I I do I have missed
things that were within my circle and
that's a terrible mistake those are my
biggest mistakes you haven't seen them
and but I don't it's not a mistake
because I miss Netscape or something
like that at all I would say that maybe
five percent of the companies or ten
percent of the companies that most are
within an area my circle of confidence
there's something I should be able to
understand what were your biggest
obstacles or mistakes
that you have faced and how did you
overcame it and maybe you can also give
us the students here a piece of advice
and that will be very amazing thank you
[Applause]
well to be frank I've made so many
mistakes that it would take far too long
for me to list them all
um
so I I would know what about people with
the extremely long list of mistakes that
I've made in the past
um but I think that the the higher
principle here is that it is always too
aspire to be less wrong over time so to
acknowledge that you'll always be to
some degree wrong but that you wish to
be less wrong over time and and uh
and if you can be a little less wrong
every day I think you're doing great
um it's it's hard to be less wrong every
day but frankly even if you could be
less wrong most days that that's a
pretty big victory
um
you know a number of things that I've
said before publicly so
um you know I think it's important to to
place weight upon both the heart and the
mind not simply the mind
um some of the biggest mistakes that
I've made in terms of hiring people have
been when they were
strong of mind but not apart the hybrid
higher principle is just assume you're
wrong and you want to be less wrong and
just try to be less wrong every day
seek critical feedback especially from
Friends
um often your friends will know what
what you are what what you're saying is
wrong but they don't want to hurt your
feelings so they won't tell you but if
you ask them to tell you and say that it
won't hurt your feelings then they will
tell you
so I think getting critical feedback
from friends is very helpful once you
have a fear
that you might be wrong
but you have still the audaciousness and
courage to go forward
you're a lot smarter
than the person who thinks they know
there's a there's a quote that Jefferson
said
he who knows he knows not is closer to
the truth than he whose mind is filled
with falsehoods
and and so when you know that and with
and then with your character and your
determination you go forward the
smartest people I know
are the most humble
it what the more you learn the more you
realize oh I'm eager to take in so
that's right
um but back on your audience
I I think your audience ranges from um
you know there's a wide range that you
have in your audience
and I would say that there are many
people in your audience
who can plan
for a simple lifestyle that can be
wonderful sometimes we acquire these
needs that aren't at anywhere near as
big as as we make them out to be
um you know
um do you have a bed to sleep in do you
have food to eat do you have basic
health care
okay if you start to think okay what are
my needs that I really need and I'm okay
and how can I make Provisions for those
needs
then once you've got that in your mind
you're you're free okay you you can go
beyond that that you may say listen oh I
can do that for a year or two years or a
month or whatever but you I think we
visualize too much the things that we're
used to one of the good things about
this exercise is that you can bring it
brings you back to basics you can be
brought to Basics and like I'm saying if
you have a bed to sleep in and you've
got food
and so on and you have those Basics and
and good relationships with people who
care about your basic health care so if
you budget for that and you figure how
do you have it maybe it isn't in the
luxurious place you're in maybe it's in
the country and so on once you visualize
that and you get that down in your head
and you say oh I can get that
then your stress will disappear because
you as you visualize that in many ways
that's a happy life it doesn't take a
lot to there's stimulation there's
nature there's relationships these
fundamental
wonderful things the most important
things can be obtained and so for many
of you I think if you look at that and
you budget for that I'm seeing a number
of people
um who are
um going broke
uh and and I've watched this over many
years
and really it's just the adjustment
process when that once they get to that
point where ah you know they have they
get settled
they're fine
it's the ambiguity it's the worry it's
the stress so if you do that from the
beginning and you have that that played
out in your head then you know
everything from there you can play with
and it's your it's uh icing on the cake
so I want to emphasize you can budget
for that you can look at that find that
scenario
find what that looks like so that you
know you've got it down then you know
you're safe once you've got safe
everything beyond that is luxury how do
you identify what's next
you know I I just read a lot right I'm
just one of those guys that just
consumes information the internet or
where everything yeah everything
anywhere I can get I just try to learn
you've always been this way yeah yeah
I've always been like a knowledge geek
where it mostly Tech but it could be
anything I just anything business
related technology related marketing
related you know um culture related I
want to try to stay on top of it you
know Steve Steve Jobs had this this one
quote that really stuck with me he said
everything's a remix and if you look at
the early days of the Apple products
there was this company back in the day
called Xerox Park and Xerox came out
with the first Mouse driven PC
but their marketing sucked and they had
no idea what they were doing no one knew
what they're about Steve Jobs gave me a
little bit of this a little bit remixed
and Bam right all of a sudden you got
apple and then a Macintosh and then
they're yeah he made it sexier yeah and
then even he got fired right he got
fired from that company and then they
had to bring him back to make it work
and so you know for me the more you
learn the more you know how to remix and
that's what this is all about so you
know how do you go from YouTube which
was the first platform for video that
got big to Instagram to Snapchat I know
okay do I want to be on Discover do I
want to be on reels do I want to be on
Tick Tock you know and if I do this you
know how's YouTube going to treat me and
all the decisions you guys you guys have
got to make on a daily basis you know
and the fact that like we're just
talking you created all these products
and you want it to be organic that's a
business decision too and then you have
to learn by trial and error right you
were curious about what might work you
know obviously you know you're walking
proof of what does work right and now
you've got to be able to continue to
make those decisions because in this
business with all the margins on these
projects everybody's coming at you all
the time right yeah and they think they
can do the exact same thing but it's not
that easy but for me it's like that's
why I try to stay ahead because whether
it's artificial intelligence whether
it's VR whether it's crypto whether it's
metaverse all these things may not be
prime time yet but I want to know when
they will be and I want to be out front
when they when they are there are so
many problems in this world
um and trying to prioritize you know
which problems uh to solve and which you
just feel you don't have the energy for
or the resources for is is a really
tough one
um which is why we're trying to get like
you know every single business in this
room
um even if you're a really small
business I love this kid of
um whatever it was eight coming up to me
and pitching me earlier in the in the
corridor
um but um but
[Laughter]
um
uh but I think that if if
um every single person in this room uh
can adopt at least one problem and and
you know like you know if it's just uh
you know trying to find a roof over the
the person you keep walking by who's
sleeping in the street every day you
know going to your office if you know
something you know but just a a problem
in this world
um I think
um you know the every single person in
this room will feel you know that much
better for it you know uh in 50 years
time when they've looked back on their
life and their careers and
um and obviously as you as businesses
get bigger you can you can you can um
adopt bigger and bigger and bigger
problems and you can use your
entrepreneurial skills your resources
your teams to take on on some of the
really big problems of this world
um and I think uh you we cannot let
business let government try to sort
problems the world have they haven't got
the entrepreneurial skills generally to
do so
[Music]
um
uh so and it's great fun I mean you know
we we have um uh we have something
called audacious ideas gathering on
Necker every year where we get some of
the more successful people together and
we uh we get throughout the year with
with Ted
um we get maybe 300 companies sorry 300
organizations to pitch
um and then we choose 10 of the of the
most important things in the world to
try to resolve and then we go out to try
to resolve them every year and you know
it could be a particular kind of
blindness in Africa
um uh you know it could be you know how
do we sort out methane leaks around the
world and you know can we use satellites
to spot them and and then alert the
companies these methane leaks
um and so on and and so uh you know so
as you get as you get as your businesses
get more successful you become more
entrepreneurially aware as to how to
look at situations in this world
um then then you get into a position
where you can actually start tackling
some of the bigger issues I am not here
to satisfy you I am not here so you like
oh oh Grant I like him I don't care if
you like me or not man I want to move a
handful of people in the room to go from
400 Grand a year to start thinking about
how do I make four million big boy right
over here popping out what do you what'd
you make last year
what'd you gross last year
2.7 how does
[Music]
you need to make it impossible dude I
cannot I can't my my plane eats 2.7
million dollars a year this this dude
needs to think different
he's running out of time man you guys
all in the room man you're running out
of time you're in a space that is so
frothy with opportunity it's
unbelievable you're making sense of less
than you can get this is my mama my
mama's saying I love you boy just the
way you are Mama I made 10 million one
deal that's great but son I love you
just the way you are I'm like
I don't love me just the way I am
because I'm doing deals where I know I
could make a hundred
okay how many of you in a room are
operating below your potential let me
see a hand if you know you're operating
below your potential man please tell me
your Opera how many of you let me see
your hand again if you're operating
below your potential
okay your finances should indicate that
your finances are a way to tell the
truth about who you are your space like
if you're an Uber driver and you're
making 2.7 million a year
pat on the back
you're in this space making 2.7 million
here come on man your company's doing
what 2 billion
two billion dollars and you guys aren't
getting it all would you say that you're
not getting it up
a lot of room he's telling me he's in
the first Innings of his game so so I'm
like hey what what do I need to do let's
say 400 is the number then I'm gonna
take this and I'm just going to 10x that
and I'm gonna build a business plan for
four million dollars
and I'm going to quit thinking I'm going
to quit thinking that I that I got to do
a four minute mile
I'm going to quit thinking about the
physical Universe what can I do to
produce four million dollars Within
is it here is it outside of here is it
here and outside of here how many
customers would I need this is what this
is what my goal for you today is to
leave here and say dude I ain't
satisfied
okay I want to raise the numbers on this
room so the next time there's 75 people
here and everybody adds a zero to your
income oh by the way if you love
yourself at 400 Grand mama
if you love your son just the way he is
at 400 would you love me a little more
if I add a zero no she couldn't love me
anymore it wasn't up to her to love me
it was up to me to love what I'm doing
every day right you guys are showing up
you're working your ass off every day
right or wrong
how many of you making calls every day
you're like I do not want to make this
call and you make it anyway good then
get paid for it
get paid some real money for it man okay
get paid some real money just add a zero
how many calls would I have to make is
this even possible he's doing part of it
he told me I'm not he's not tapped into
all of it
he's hitting 70 percent of that number
if everybody walked out of here and said
hey I'm gonna build a four million
dollar plan I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna
tell you a little a little game I play I
got 14 little companies I run 14 little
companies while I'm doing deals while
I'm speaking to you today right I'm
still running them in my head right now
I got them all open I got browsers open
all over the place
counselor said you got add I said I
ain't got add I don't know how to add I
multiply
I'm done adding I'm done adding a
customer I want to multiply customers I
wanna I don't want to add orders I want
to multiply my orders okay I consider
myself a decent salesperson
but it doesn't matter if you're a great
salesperson if you don't add business to
the sale if you don't become a business
person you can't build out zeros because
you're going to hit you're going to hit
a place where they can't pay you anymore
right or wrong
you got to start thinking about being a
business inside the business
how do I add zeros how do I grow the top
line of my business okay so today I'm
thinking I'm thinking man I'm going to
build a mo I'm going to build a 10
billion dollar business I just go in and
do it backwards I'm going to build a 10
billion dollar business I'm gonna take
the 14 little things that I have
probably get down to three or four how
do I build 10 billion
I know the money's on the planet
say yay if you agree there's 10 billion
dollars on planet Earth dude you could
you could suck 10 billion dollars off
planet Earth today and you wouldn't they
wouldn't even give you like you wouldn't
even make the paper
I just got to think different and I
can't compare it to my upbringing
[Music]
because you made a this far in a video I
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for the
Five Lessons you can't afford to learn
too late in life check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe then I'll see you
there as much as possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job I mean don't sleep
walk through life and don't don't say
it's all going to be great you know I'll
do this and I'll do that and